من يعترض على تعديل قانون الارث المسيحي
في الاردن يبرر رايه بان الاردني المسيحي
جزء لا يتجزا من النسيج الاردني ولا يجب
ان يتم الانسلاخ عنه باي شكل كان احنا
كمسيحيين مسموح من الزواج الطلاق
التسجيل الاولاد الى اخره من قضايانا
الشؤون الخاصه او الشؤون المدنيه ليش هاي
بس اللي تركت وطلعت من شو اسمه لانه واضح
انه كان في ضغط مجتمعي وليس ديني وليس اي
شيء اخر هو ضغط مجتمعي ما بدهم يعني
بعقلهم التفكير ما بدهم لانه بيعتقد الرجل
انه حصه الاراضي اللي عنده او او املاكه
لا يجوز ان تطلع لغريب خاصه اذا كان جوز
بنته غريب وهي قضايا على فكره من العيب
انه نفكر فيها لانه انا لما بحكي بحكي مع
بنتي بحكي مع مش مش جوز بنتي يعني انا
بحكي مع بنتي بصير زي ابني فانت تل
جا الاسر الان لقضيه انه هو بيسجل كل ما
يملك باسماء بناته حتى ما يدخلش ناس عليه
من الورثه وهو عايش
انا بدي
يوصل صوتي حتى لو ما حلفني انا الحظ وما
وما اخذت انا حقي وحتى لو ما انطبق علي
شروط ما عندي مشكله انا بكون مبسوطه
وممنونه اذا غيري بستفيد
بتغيير القانون